[موسيقى]
لا حديث هذه الايام في فلسطين سوى عن
الاستيطان وتوسيعه والمستوطنين وجرائمهم
تطورات متلاحقه تاتي كلها في اعقاب تلك
الخطوه التي اتخذتها الحكومه الاسرائيليه
والقاضيه بتفويض رئيس حزب الصهيونيه
الدينيه ووزير الماليه والوزير في وزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه المستوطن المتطرف
باسرائيل
صلاحيات تخوله تسهيل اجراءات عمليات
الاستيطان وتسريعه الجانب الفلسطيني وصف
القرار بالتصعيد الخطير لانه سيقود الى ضم
اجزائن واسعه من الضفه الغربيه الى
اسرائيل خاصه وقد تلاهوا الاعلان عن بناء
الالاف من الوحدات الاستيطانيه الجديده
فما الذي يعنيه هذا القرار وما تداعياته
المختلفه فلسطينيا واسرائيليا ولماذا تصر
الحكومه الاسرائيليه على فرض سياسه الامر
الواقع وواد حل الدولتين وتجاهل المطالب
الدوليه اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من
سيناريوه
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم قراره تفويضريتش بشان
الاستيطان جاء بهدفي حرق المراحل وتقصير
الاجراءات لتسهيل تنفيذ المخططات
الاستيطانيه الكبرى التي من شانها ضم
اجزاء كبيره من الاراضي المحتله وعزل شمال
الضفه عن جنوبها في تجاهل كامل للقراره
والمواقف الدوليه في هذا الشان لمعرفه
ابعاد هذا القرار ومدى خطورته وتداعياته
على ارض الواقع يسعدنا ان يكون معنا هنا
في هذه الحلقه في الاستوديو والدكتور احمد
جميل عزم استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جماعه
قطر من القدس الدكتور احمد الطيبي النائب
العربي في الكنيسه الاسرائيلي ومن رام
الله الدكتور صبري صيدا نائب اميني سر
اللجنه المركزيه لحركه فتح ووزير التعليم
الفلسطيني الاسبق فاهلا بهم جميعا
قرروا الحكومه الاسرائيليه بتفويض وزير
مستوطن لتسهيل اجراءات عمليات الاستيطان
وتسريعها اثار شهيه المستوطنين واغراهم
بالعبث داخل الاراضي المحتله وبمزيد من
الاعتداءات على الارض والانسان الفلسطيني
كما اثار في المقابل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
للرد بعمليات النوعيه
تحلق طائره الاباتشي الاسرائيليه لقصف
مواقع في مخيم جنين انها المره الاولى منذ
الانتفاضه الثانيه وليس هذا حدثا عابرا او
مجرد ضروره املتها الحاجه الاسرائيليه
لتعزيز ملاحقاتها للفلسطينيين انها كما
تدل التطورات السريعه في الضفه الغربيه
مرحله تحول في الممارسات الاسرائيليه
فبينما تتصاعد اعتداءات المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين على الفلسطينيين في بلداتهم
وقراهم تحث حكومتهم الخطى لتقويض حلم
اقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه في هذا السياق
يقرا قرار حكومه نتنياهو تسريع مراحل
النمو الاستيطاني في الضفه كانت تصديق على
اي خطه استيطانيه جديده يستغرق مراحل
اهمها الاعلان عن المخطط ونشره في الصحف
والاعتراض عليه ثم اقرار ميزانيته
والتصديق عليه في مستويين المستوى السياسي
ممثلا في الحكومه والجيش لا يتطلب الامر
بعد الان موافقه هذين المستويين كما ظل
منذ ربع قرن صار متوقفا على قرار هذا
الرجل
بتسلى وزير الماليه والوزير في وزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه وليس هذا التحول قطعا
للطريق امام المعارضه الداخليه فقط للخطط
الاستيطانيه بل يحول د مع اي اعتراض او
ممانعه اوروبيه او امريكيه وذاك ما دفع
الامين العامه للامم المتحده
الى التاكيد في تقريره الفصلي ان جميع
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله بما في ذلك القدس الشرقيه ليس لها
اي شرعيه قانونيه
ما يعرف عن سموتريش منذ وصوله للحكومه انه
شرعن 9 بؤر استيطانيه ورفع الميزانيه
المخصصه للاستيطان باربعه مليارات شيكل
ومع القرار الاخير بتسريع اجراءات
الاستيطان يعتقد ان مساعي ضم الضفه
الغربيه تتحول الى واقع عملي انها مشاريع
اليمين المتطرف المسيطر على القرار داخل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بهدف دعم الاستيطان
السياحي وتحسين خدمات البنى التحتيه في
المستوطنات والبؤر الاستيطانيه يحقق ذلك
للاسرائيليين هدف عزل شمال الضفه عن
جنوبها لكن الامر لا يقتصر على هذا ثمه
معركه ديموغرافيه تخوضها حكومه نتنياهو
لتحقيق اكثريه مطلقه لليهود واقليه للعرب
في الضفه بما يحول دون امكانيه اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه بينما تظهر معطيات مركز الاحصاء
الاسرائيلي تراجع نسبه المستوطنين هناك
وارتفاع اعداد المهاجرين منهم للسكن في
المركز والجنوب ما تخوده الحكومه
الاسرائيليه حقا هو سباق مع الزمن
دكتور احمد جميل عازم اهلا وسهلا فيك ما
اخطر ما يمكن ان ينجم عن هذا التفويض
باداره ملف الاستيطان ككل هو يتم تفويض
الصهيونيه الدينيه يتم تفويض تيار متكامل
ليس فقط يعني نحن نلاحظ انه في الاعلام
الجميع يتحدث عن تفويضتش ليس عن تفويض
وزير الماليه او عن وزير الدفاع يعني
وكانه الموضوع اصبح شخصي جدا وهو هذا
بالفعل لانه لا نحن امام شخص مع بنغفير مع
نتنياهو يشكلون ثلاثتهم بشكل شخصي عقليه
صهيونيه يعني هي الاكثر تطرفا حتى الان
لديهم اهمال كامل للقانون الاسرائيلي نفسه
دائما اهمال كامل لفكره القضاء لديهم فقط
قناعه خاصه خصص موتريتش يتحدث فقط عن فكر
توراتي داعشي شخص عمره 43 سنه يحتل لا
يملك اكثر حزبه الصهيوني الدينيه لا تملك
اكثر من 6% اقل بالميه من اعضاء الكنيست
ولكن رغم ذلك يمتلك وزرتين مهمات جدا
الماليه ووزير في وزاره الدفاع ويمتلك
الان صلاحيه ملف الاستيطان ولديه دعم كبير
من يهود صهاينه في اوروبا في فرنسا في
غيرها حتى يكون رجل المرحله المقبله رغم
انه ما زال يعني نحن نتحدث عن مشروع يتم
الاستثمار في للمستقبل الصهيونيه الدينيه
تيار كان دائما لدينا صهيونيه العلمانيه
والتيار الديني الان صهيوني الدينيه مع
اشخاص في عمر صغير نسبيا دعم كبير حتى من
داخل الوقود الاسرائيلي انصار الليكود
اليمين بات يرى في اشخاص اسماء مثلج
ومشروعهم الداعشي بالمعنى
المتطرف مشروعهم الذي لا يؤمن
بالديموغرافيه وفكره انه ممكن يحدث توازن
ديموغرافي فلسطيني اسرائيليه ام فرض وقائع
على الارض فنحن امام جهه لا يوجد لديها
كوابح لا في قانون الدولي ولا الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي نحن امام فوضى امام جنون مقبل
ولكن ان يتم اسقاط راي المؤسسه الامنيه
والدفاعيه
والمؤسسه السياسيه ككل واقتزال الموضوع في
شخص واحد تراه تفويضا لهذا التيار باكمله
وليس لشخص طبعا هو لتيار كامل وهذا التيار
خطير جدا حتى على اسرائيل نفسها ولكن
نتنياهو ورغبته في البقاء ورغبته في تفادي
المحاكمه يجعله يقبل تقديم اي شيء حتى انه
في يوم من الايام يمكن ان ينافس نتنياهو
نفسه ولكن نحن هو احد ممثلي ما يسمى شبيبه
التلال مجموعه من الشباب الاسرائيلي
اليهودي المتطرف الذي يؤمن بالعنف المطلق
ضد العرب والان ينتشرون في منطقه شمال
الضفه الغربيه بشكل اساسي
يعبر عن يعني مجموعه حاخامات اللي بامنوا
بعقيده سميت عقيده الامالك او العماليق
الذين يقولون للجنود اذا جاءتكم تعليمات
من السياسيين بامور مثل انسحاب من مستوطنه
عليكم ان تخالفوا التعليمات نحن نتحدث عن
تيار يريد ان يبني بنكفير يبني جيش جديد
ميليشيا من المتطوعين الحرس الوطني
فبالتالي نحن امام تيار يعني هو يذهب
بعيدا في محاوله تغيير الواقع على الارض
من خلال ايضا تغيير الواقع الاسرائيلي
لضرب مؤسسه القضاء الاسرائيليه ضرب الجيش
الاسرائيلي نفسه يتم الان نزع صلاحياته
لصالح هذه الميليشيات ولصالح هؤلاء
الاشخاص فبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن تحولات
مهمه تحدث في المشهد الفلسطيني من خلال ما
يحدث داخل الجانب الاسرائيلي هذه التحولات
دكتور احمد الطيبي في القدس تاتي في دوله
تزعم بانها دوله ديمقراطيه دوله مؤسسات
وقانون كيف يمكن ان نفوض ملف بمثل هذه
الحساسيه بالمعنى الامني والاستراتيجي
لشخص واحد ولتيار ديني متطرف هل هذا يعني
انه
سيتم الامساك بالكامل في المستقبل بهذا
الملف
عندما
تمت عمليه تشكيل هذه الحكومه والائتلاف
نتنياهو كان خاضعا
لابتزازات
خضع لها من قبل
الصهيونيه المتدينه بزعامه
من جهه اخرى
لدرجه ان سمتريتش حاز هو وحده على
ملفين هامين وزاره الماليه التي تسيطر على
كل مفاصل الحياه في الدوله ووزير في وزاره
الامن مسؤولا عن ملف الاستيطان عن منطقه
جيم وغيرها
نتنياهو لم يكن في
ذهنه سوى قضيه واحده ان يصبح رئيسا ووزراء
مهما كلف الثمن لانه اذا لم يصبح رئيسا
الوزراء في هناك مشاكل قضائيه محاكم مع
انه اليوم قبل قليل في هناك تطور
دراماتيكي في محكمه لصالحه انه ما يسمى
ملف 4000 القضاه قالوا للادعاء انه في
الشون تهمه رشوه لا قد لا تثبت عليه
بنهايه المطاف
الائتلاف فرض نفسه
والسموتريتش لديه فكر وايدولوجيه صهيونيه
دينيه عميقه وعلى فكره كثيرون دائما
يذكرون اسم بينج فير ولكنه وكانه الاكثر
تطرفا الاكثر تطرفا وخطوره فكرا وممارسه
وموقعا هو اسمه اكثر من بنجفير الصبياني
ولذلك الاداره الامريكيه
حاولت
ونجحت نوعا ما كان لها دور في منع من ان
يصبح وزيرا للامن لانه كان قد طلب ان يصبح
وزيرا للامن او وزيرا للماليه واعطائه
حقيبه في وزاره الامن كان حل وسط
الان لمن يعرف
لديه خطه خطه عمل طرحها مستقبلا فكر وخطه
اللي هي خطه اخضاع الفلسطينيين كما قال
انه من يريد ان يبقى هنا
ليكون من الرعايه الذين يقبلون بان يكون
يكون رعايه تحت السلطه اليهوديه
او ان
يغادروا يرحلوا او ان يكون الجيش
بفعل ما يستطيع ضد من لا يوافق هذه الثلاث
خيارات التي يطرحها في مقاله الفكري انذاك
طبعا هو يود ان يكون في هناك ضم انسيشن
لن يكون هذه الحكومه لن تعلن الضم نظرا
للمواقف الدوليه
بهذا الموضوع ولكن
خطوه هنا خطوه هناك الف وحده سكنيه هنا
4000 وحده سكنيه تقصير عمليه
شرعنه الاستيطان بانه هو المرجعيه وليس
وزير الامن او الجيش ولكن يجب ان نقول
الحقيقه بنهايه المطاف المسؤوليه الاولى
هي لرئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو هو الذي
يستطيع ان يوقف او ان يسمح وحاليا هو يسمح
بهذه الامور وتعزيز الاستيطان وكل حكومه
تاتي
اليمين فيها ينافس كيف يعزز الاستيطان
اكثر هكذا فعلت الحكومه السابقه نفتالي
بنت وايلد وتفاخر بالميزانيات وهكذا يفعل
سم
وبنيامين نتنياهو لارضاء هذا اللوبي القوي
عندما نتحدث عن عن هذا القرار الدكتور
صبري صيدم نتحدث ايضا عن تداعياته
الفلسطينيه عندما نرى بعض الشخصيات
الاسرائيليه تكتب بعض التقارير في الصحف
او بعض التقديرات الامنيه يتحدثون عن
تداعيات خطيره حتى بالنسبه للسلطه هم
يعتقدون بان السلطه الان في حاله حرج وضعف
وان هذا قد يدفعها في ضوء ما يجري حاليا
اما للتنصل الكامل من اتفاقيه اوسلو او
حتى الاندثار او الانهيار وهذا بالنسبه
لكثير من الاسرائيليين هو سيناريو الرعب
كما وصفه احدهم هل هل تخشى السلطه من
تداعيات من هذا القبيل
اسمح لي ان اقول بدايه تحيه لارواح
الشهداء وتحيه لاسرانا وجرحانا نحن امام
عمل ابادي بامتياز تريد حكومه الاحتلال
الاجهاز على الهويه الفلسطينيه وترحيل
الفلسطينيين وهي لا تلقي ذبال لا للسلطه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ولا لاحد هي تؤمن الان
بان عليها تسريع عمليه اباده الفلسطينيين
او ترحيلهم واصالهم الى ذات النتيجه التي
بدات فيها النكبه عن خمس قرن 75 عام قبل
1948 عندما شاءت ان يرحل الفلسطينيين
والانس وجوده هو يستحق بامتياز لقب وزير
الاباده لا وزير دفاع ولا وزير ماليه لانه
ربما تكون هذه المناصب لها وقع في نوع من
الاحترام لدى بعض الدول ولكن هو وزير
اباده بامتياز هو يبحث عن ترحيل
الفلسطينيين الرجل لديه مشروع هو اصلا
ينكر وجود الفلسطينيين وقال بانه لا وجود
لمسمى فلسطيني ولديه توصفات خاصه ورايتهم
في فرنسا كيف
خارطه وضع عليها خارطه فلسطين وخارطه
الاردن وهو يبحث في الفكر الازاحي القائم
على ارضيه الترحيل وتوسيع اسرائيل لتكون
اسرائيل الكبرى وما زال الشعار موجود على
ابواب الكنيسه دوله اسرائيل من الفرات الى
النيل وبالتالي احنا امام هذه العقليه
التي تعيد احياء الماضي تعيد احياء مفهوم
عصابات ستان وارجون والكهنه والتي تحاول
قدر الامكان الان ان تزرع الرعب في قلوب
الفلسطينيين وعليه هو لا يرى بان السلطه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه اصلا تستحق الحياه ولا
يرى ان الشعب الفلسطيني يستحق اي سلطه
وبصراحه ان كان هناك حل يفكر في بعض
الاسرائيليين هو يرى بانه الترتيب في غزه
يكون ترتيب امني والترتيب في الضفه الغربي
يكون ترتيب بلدي يعني قائم على بعض
البلديات المواليه الاحتلال والتي تسير
حياه الفلسطينيين لذلك احنا امام مرحله
خطيره نطق ناقوس الخطر امام الجميع بانه
هناك عمليه اباده تجري الان وما القرارات
الصادره في موضوع معاقبه الاسرى اعدام
الناشطين ترحيل الفلسطينيين بناء المزيد
من المستوطنات الا كلها تدور في ذات
الحلقه وفي ذات العقيده القائمه على مفهوم
انطق القوه يتغلب على قوه المنطق وهكذا هو
نتنياهو وهكذا هو من جفير وكل الائتلاف
الحكومي الذي يدور في فلكهم جميعا
على كل الموضوع الاستيطاني الاسرائيلي في
الضفه الغربيه ما يزال وكذلك في القدس
المحتله ما زال ينهش الارض ويستحوذ عليها
مصادره وضما وعزنا حتى لا يكاد الفلسطيني
يجد له فيها موطئه قدم فقد اظهرت تقارير
الاسرائيليه جديده ان البناء الاستيطاني
في الضفه الغربيه المحتله تضاعف وسجل
ارقاما قياسيه جديده منذ تشكيل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الحاليه قبل زهاء سته اشهر
تست اسرائيل تصنيف الاراضي الفلسطينيه
بحسب اتفاقيه اوسلو الى الف وباء وجيم
بهدف احكام سيطرتها على الاراضي المصنفه
جيم تشكل المنطقه جيم نحو 61% من مساحه
الضفه وهي تحت السيطره الاسرائيليه
الكامله امنيا واداريا بينما تشكل مناطق
الف وباء مجتمعه 39% من الضفه وتخضع نظريا
للسلطه الفلسطينيه يبلغ عدد المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه في الضفه الغربيه المحتله 199
بما فيها الكتل الاستيطانيه اضافه الى 220
بؤره استيطانيه تبلغ مساحه البناء
للمستوطنات 200 كم مربع وهو ما يقارب
ثلاثه ونصف في المئه من مساحه الضفه
الغربيه كما تبلغ المساحه الواقعه تحت
النفوذ المستوطنات اكثر من 500 واربعين
كيلو مترا مربعا ما يعادل نحو تسعه في
المئه من مساحه الضفه وبشكل اوضح فان 68%
من مساحه المنطقه جين في الضفه تمت
السيطره عليها لمصلحه المستوطنات وهو
نسبته 42% من مساحه الضفه الغربيه وهذه
المنطقه تضم 87% من موارد الضفه الطبيعيه
وتسعين بالمئه من غاباتها كما اقامت سلطات
الاحتلال ما يزيد عن 200 قاعده عسكريه على
مساحه تزيد على خمسه واربعين مترا مربع
تمتد شبكه الطرق الالتفافيه الواقعه تحت
سيطره سلطات الاحتلال نحو 950 كيلومترا في
الضفه الغربيه بما في ذلك القدس المحتله
يمتد جدار الفصل العنصري مسافه اكثر من
770 كيلومترا على طول الجزء الغربي من
الضفه وفي المنطقه جيم هذه لا تزيد
المساحه التي يسمح للفلسطينيين باستخدامها
بشكل عملي عن واحد في المئه يقطن في
المستوطنات والبؤر الاستيطانيه ما يزيد
على 900 الف مستوطن منهم 350 الفا في
القدس الشرقيه وحدها
دكتور عزم يعني تقريبا لم يبقى شيء من
الضفه الغربيه يعني عندما نتحدث عن هذه
المشاريع ويتم الحديث عن فصل
شمال الضفه عن وسطها وعن جنوبها هل هذا
سنراه قريبا يعني نحن لم نتحدث عن اكثر من
ستين بالميه من اراد الضفه الغربيه مصنفه
بانها مناطق جيم ويمنع البناء الفلسطيني
فيها و68 بها من هذه المنطقه مستوطنات
يعني هذه المستوطنات ربما تستحل تحتل
حوالي 4% من الارض ولكن الاراضي التي وضعت
لها الشوارع الان في هناك شوارع حواجز لما
نتحدث عن اكثر من سيات 100 حاجز موجوده
ممكن تفعيلها خلال دقائق في الضفه الغربيه
انت تخرج من بيتك في فلسطين ولا تعرف اذا
كنت ستصل عملك ولا ستجد حاجز او اكثر
وبالتالي الحياه وجد يعني يتم التضييق
بشكل كبير جدا للحياه حتى تخرج الناس من
فلسطين ولكن ربما هذه السياسه الحكومات
السابقه الان لدينا حكومه جديده
وغيره الذين دون ايضا ايقاع العقوبات
الجماعيه يريدون ان الان يهدم بيت اي
مناضل يقوم بعمليه فدائيه او نضاليه الان
يريدون قوانين جديده السيناريو الجديد هو
ان تهدم قرى باكملها نحن ردينا كما راينا
نفسه عندما هدد او اراد ان تحرق حواره في
قريتنا وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن يعني اولا
في واقع على الارض اماكن البناء المسموحه
للفلسطينيين المحدوده جدا يعني نحن نواجه
احيانا اوضاع لا يتخيل العقل يعني ممنوع
على الفلسطينيين على سبيل المثال مد شبكه
مجاري وفي نهايه كل شهر تقتطع اسرائيل من
عائدات الضرائب الفلسطينيه مقاصه من او
تسمى المقاصه بدل تكرير مياه المجاري وانت
تمنع الفلسطيني ان يكرر المجاري وتاخذ
المياه الصالحه وتعيد للفلسطينيين فاتوره
الدفع يعني هذا الواقع السلطه التي يراد
ان تكون ضعيفه فقط موجوده كشكل امام
العالم
[موسيقى]
هناك جزء لا يستهان به من هذه المستوطنات
فارغ وهو بالتالي معد حتى ياتي اليه
مهاجرين مبالغ يباع باسعار زهيده ربع ثمن
شقه في منطقه بلعين تباع بعيده عن تل ابيب
شيء بسيط الدقائق تباع بربع ثمن وبالتالي
هذا موجود النمط البناء الاستيطاني مؤخرا
بدا يختلف هناك تفاصيل تختلف يعني مثلا
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه تاريخيا كانت نمط
اوروبي كرميد احمر الطريقه الاوروبيه الان
بدات تبنى وكانها احياء عربيه
فبدات حتى تختفي يعني يصعب احيانا التمييز
على غير ابناء المنطقه هذا هذه كلها
تغيرات مهمه تجري على الارض
كوزير ماليه يدفع ويمول هذا الاستيطان
يمول حركات استيطانيه مهمه يعني كما قال
الدكتور صبري صيدا في خطاب وفي باريس وذهب
مدعوا من الليكود نشاطين الليكود في باريس
الذين يريدون منه كوزير ماليه ان يمول
جامعه ويمول جامعات ومؤسسات
لليمين الاستيطاني في المقابل هم يمولونه
هم يسمنونه تسمين سياسي حتى يستمر كما قال
الدكتور احمد الطيب يتم الان تجاهله لا
يدعى للاجتماعات واضح انهم يتعاملوا معك
الظاهره صبيانيه عابره ولكن شيء خطير هناك
صهيونيه دوليه تدعمه وتريد ان يستمر فيها
وهو رغم انه لا يشكل حقيقه الان بثقل بين
الناخبين الاسرائيلي الكبير ولكنه يراد له
ان يصبح كذلك وبالتالي يراد له ان يصبح
لاعب اساسي في السياسه وهذا امر خطير لانه
يمثل تيار تيار شبيبه التلال تيار
العماليق الحاخامات الذين يدعون الى
التمرد على القضاء الاسرائيلي الخامات
الذين يريدون التمرد على الجيش الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن اقصى يمين اليمين
الذي يمثله مشروع الاستيطاني يريد لا يريد
فقط
بناء مستوطنات اسرائيليه ولكن يريد ازاله
قرى عربيه
الغريبه او الملفت للنظر ربما الدكتور
احمد الطيبي ان رغم ان الاستيطان في
الشرعيه الدوليه طبعا غير شرعي غير قانوني
هذا ما اكد عليه اخيرا بشكل واضح الامين
العام للامم المتحده حتى الولايات المتحده
تنظر الى الموضوع على انها عقبه في طريق
السلام كما تقول في حين كانت في السابق
تقول انها غير شرعيه يعني سر هذا الاصرار
الاسرائيلي على تجاهل الجميع كانها تقول
للكل يعني اسمح لي روحوا بلطوا البحر انا
سافعل ما اريد
يعني من اين تستمد اسرائيل هذه القوه في
مواجهه العالم كله تقريبا في هذه المساله
اقول لك بصراحه من العالم كله من المجتمع
الدولي الذي
يدفع ضريبه كلاميه فيما يتعلق بالاستيطان
كما تفضلت اخي محمد بالصابق الاداره
الامريكيه كانت تصف المستوطنات بانها غير
شرعيه وعقبه امام السلام
ازالت كلمه غير شرعيه وتكتفي الان
بعقبه امام السلام اكثر من ذلك انظر ماذا
يفعل المستوطنون في حواره احراق حواره
واحراق ترمس عياء وغيرها من البلدات
الفلسطينيه ماذا يفعل المجتمع الدولي نحن
نتحدث عن مستوطنين اللي هم
جريمه حرب الاستيطان هو جريمه حرب وان
يقوموا بحرق الصور لوحدها كافيه بان تحرك
العالم الذي لا يتحرك
ولذلك يقول لنفسه
اللي غير مرغوب فيه في عواصم مختلفه غربيه
لا في واشنطن ولا في باريس دبلوماسيا
وسياسيا ولكنه له ولن يتنياهو
لا احد يحاسبهم اسرائيل فوق القانون
الدولي وفوق المحاسبه لانها لا تحاسب حتى
عندما يتم
تصور لو مجموعه من الفلسطينيين ذهبوا لحرق
مستوطنه لحرق مستوطنه اللي فيها ناس
مجرمون بحق الشعب الفلسطيني الاداره
الامريكيه كانت ستتحرك اكثر الامم المتحده
المجتمع الدولي
الالفاظ التي كانت تستعمل ستكون مختلفه
اما اهل ترمس جزء منهم مواطنين امريكيين
فالتصريحات هي تصريحات ضريبه كلاميه نحن
امام مجرم
مجرموه حرب الذين يعيشون فسادا لان العالم
يسمح لهم بان يجرموا بان يرتكبوا هذه
الجرائم هذه الحكومه فش فيها ولا وزير
مثلا يعترف بوجود الشعب الفلسطيني على
فكره غالبيه الحكومات في الماضي لا
يعترفوا بحق تقرير المصير للشعب
الفلسطيني
انظر كيف يتم تعامل العالم مع الفلسطيني
اللي مش بس لا يوجد له حق
تقرير مصير لا يوجد له حق الدفاع عن نفسه
امام من يجيء ليحرقه ببنزين بوقود يحرقه
يحرق اهل بيته يحرق سيارته يحرق منزله انا
اريد ان اسال بصراحه والكلام قد نحاسب
عليه لماذا لا يقوم المجتمع الدولي بتسليح
الفلسطينيين في هذه البلدات
المعرضه للحرق مره ومره اخرى للدفاع عن
النفس بس للدفاع عن النفس
مش بس انه الفلسطيني لا يستطيع ان يحمل
سلاحا ليدافع عن نفسه لا باروده ولا ام 16
ولا كلاشنكوف ولا بلطه ولا ان يتظاهر لكي
يقول انه عنده حق للدفاع عن النفس عندما
يدافع عن نفسه في ترمس عيا كما هي حاله
شهيد عمر قطين
الجيش الجيش جيش الاحتلال هو الذي يطلق
عليه النار عندما يعطي هذه الحمايه لهؤلاء
المستوطنين الذين يبعثون فسادا وحرقا
للفلسطينيين في بلدتهم لهذه البلدات
الفلسطينيه الفلسطيني ممنوع ان يدافع عن
نفسه ممنوع ان يتظاهر ممنوع ان يكون انا
اعترض على الف باء وجيم والمجتمع الدولي
الغربي الديمقراطي الليبراليه
يعني يعكف عن الدفاع عن اوكرانيا
ويغض الطرف ويشيح بوجهه عما يحدث للشعب
الفلسطيني لا في القدس ولا في البلدات
الفلسطينيه المحروقه المحروقه والتي قد
تحترق ايضا في هذه الاجواء دكتور سيد ما
هي الخيارات التي بقيت للسلطه لانه بصراحه
وهؤلاء اكرر مره اخرى اسمح لي السلطه الان
في وضع صعب للغايه امام رايها العام وامام
المجتمع الدولي يعني تكاد تقريبا
تتوقف الامور عن بيانات تصدرها الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه او المندوب الفلسطيني في الامم
المتحده هل بتقديرك ستواصل السلطه الحديث
عن حل الدولتين والتسويه ومناسبه الولايات
المتحده التدخل في حين ان واضح تماما ان
هذا الاسلوب اصبح اسلوبا عقيما ولا قيمه
له
يعني اخي العزيز اولا دعنا نضع الامور في
نصابها ما تفضلوا في الضيفين العزيزين وصف
الحاله التي فيها تواطئ دولي وفيها صبط
وفيها اذعان وفيها اشعار لاسرائيل بانها
اكبر من القانون الدولي لا شك ان السلطه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه كانت بمثابه الجسر
الذي يوصل الفلسطينيين من مرحله انتقاليه
الى مرحله نهائيه تتوج باقامه الدوله
وعاصمتها القدس ولكن اسرائيل ارادت ان
تستفرد بالشعب الفلسطيني لانها ارادت من
عمليه السلام عمليه دون ان يكون هناك سلام
المحور الثاني الذي اريد ان اغطي بانه
الشعب الفلسطيني الان ضحيه ثلاث امور
رئيسيه اولا موضوع التطبيع الذي يعتبر
خنجر في صدر كل فلسطين وبالمناسبه اقول
لكل من يشاهدنا ويعتبر نفسه جزء من منظومه
التطويع ويقول كما يقول اخواننا في تونس
خاطيني ليس لي علاقه بالامر لا انت مسؤول
وانت تشاهد هذا المشهد وانت تتحمل مسؤوليه
هذه الطعنه في الصدر المحور الثاني الا
الامريكيه التي تنبطئ تماما الان تحضيرا
للانتخابات الامريكيه وبالتالي تراها
تداهن وتوارب وتحاول ان يعني تتجاوز
الحقائق على ارضيه ان الفلسطيني يعني عليه
ان يتلقى فقط البيانات وبالمناسبه القضيه
الفلسطينيه اكثر قضيه استلمت بيانات شجب
واستنكار وعبر عن القلق واصدرت بيانات
لتعبر عن اشد العبارات دون ان يكون هناك
فعل والمحور الثالث اوروبا التي تغرق في
موضوع اوكرانيا وفي موضوع روسيا وخلافه من
محاولات ايضا استرضاء العم سام لذلك الجو
العام المحيط بالسلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
هو جو غير صحي الان الشعب الفلسطيني يقاتل
انا بدي اذكر مشاهديك لانه اليوم كان في
تقرير على قناه الجزيره حقيقه تقرير محزن
بحق اجهزتنا الامنيه لانه فعليا احنا
لدينا 30 ضابط وجندي قضوا في الاشتباكات
الاخيره وانت تعرف انه بعض اولئك الذين
تميزوا اليوم النضالي كابو رعد خازم الذي
خسر شهيدين في معارك جنين هو ضابط في
الامن الفلسطيني وبالتالي كلنا في الهم
شرقه انا ضد ان يفصل الشعب الفلسطيني بان
هذا طويل وهذا قصير بصراحه يا اخي الحبيب
عندما تطلق القذيفه الاسرائيليه او تخرج
الطلقه من فوهه مسدس اسرائيلي لا تميز بين
فلسطين واخر لا على ارضيه الجنس ولا ارضيه
الفصائليه والانتماء الفصائل ولا على
ارضيه العقيده التي يمتلكها هذا الفلسطيني
هي تقاتل الكل الفلسطيني لانها تريد ازاحه
وتريد احباط وتريد تدمير وهي التي توظف
ذبابها الالكتروني من اجل النهج فينا حتى
نعود لمربع تسجيل النقاط على بعضنا البعض
وانا اتحدث بعد 15 سنه من الانقسام وبعد
الصراع الذي خيض على وكالات الاعلام
وبصراحه لم يتمخض عنه اي شيء لم نحرر انشا
من فلسطين بخلافاتنا التي توجت على
الفضائيات وحاولنا ان نسجل نقاط بعض من
البعض لا كلنا في الهم شرقه كلنا نعاني
كلنا نواجه ذات الاحتلال وكلنا ننتمي لذات
العقيده القائمه على تحرير فلسطين لانه
احنا ابناء شهداء ونحن ابناء اسرى ونحن
ابناء جرحى لا يمكن ان نتنازل عن هذه
الرساله وبالتالي احنا بنقول لاخوتنا
العرب اليوم نحن في مهنه لا نخفي باننا
نقف لوحدنا ونشعر باننا نقف لوحدنا ولكن
ردا على سؤالك الفلسطيني لا يعدم الوسيله
على الاطلاق هو يصنع المعجزه على الارض
وان تتروا هذا الاستبسال حتى اليوم حاولوا
المستوطنين ان يقتحموا ترمس ايام من جديد
تصدى الفلسطينيون ببساله ولكن دون ان يكون
هناك نفس دون ان يكون هناك اسناد سيبقى
الفلسطيني يشعر نفسه بانه يخوض هذه
المعركه لوحده كثير منا يقول يا وحدنا
ولكن احنا ثابتون ملتزمون مصرون مقاتلون
سنقاتل حتى الرمق الاخير وانا بقول بصراحه
كل ما يؤخذ من قرارات على طاوله الحكومه
الاسرائيليه يجب اخضع لقانون نيوتن في
الفيزياء لكل فعل رده فعل معاكسه بالاتجاه
ولكن مساويه بالقيمه وبالتالي عندما يفرض
على الشعب الفلسطيني ان يقاتل معركته
سيخوض هذه المعركه ببساله بامتياز باذن
الله
دكتور عزم هل مزال هناك الان اي قيمه
للحديث عن حل الدولتين قبل اسابيع كان
كانت لنا مقابله هنا في الجزيره مع الامين
العام للامم تحت
قلت الكل يتحدث عن حل الدولتين ولكن لا
احد يتحدث عن انهاء الاحتلال هو قال حل
الدولتين عمليا يعني انهاء الاحتلال ولكن
واضح ان الان هذه التعويذه حل الدولتين لم
تعد لها اي قيمه تقريبا عمليا على الارض
يعني العالم يدرك بانه اسرائيل ايضا اصبحت
دوله ابارتهايد ام لست انترناشونال او
هيومن رايس ووتش منظمات وصفتها بصراحه
بانها ابرتها وهذا وتحدث عن الابرت هايد
لانه التمييز عنصر والتهويد
واخراج الفلسطينيين لا يتعلق فقط في الضفه
الغربيه وقطاع غزه نحن نتحدث عن فلسطين من
البحر للنهر الان معرضه لهجوم وبالتالي
يعني نحن نتحدث انه ليس فقط ان نحل الدوله
الثانيه يتم القضاء عليه ولكن ايضا يتم
القضاء على الوجود الفلسطيني في كل مكان
يعني نحن نمر في مرحله جديده من التطرف
العنصري الموجود في كل مكان وهنا ربما
كمان يعني اعود لسؤالك انه مصر قوه هذا
التيار الاستيطاني الجديد جزء منه هو
تحولات حتى في الصهيونيه العالميه عندما
يعني التاريخيا كنا نتحدث في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه عن ايبك اللوبي
الاسرائيلي الان نتحدث عن ما هو اكثر
تطرفا بكثير المجلس الاسرائيلي الامريكي
اللي كان يقول شيلد اديلسون والان تقول
زوجته مريم اديسون الملياردير اليهودي
الذي توفي
هذا هذا يرفض ان يدعم حكومه اسرائيليه
تعترف بوجود الفلسطيني تعترف بان هناك شيء
اسمه فلسطيني
يجتهدون حتى يمنعوا اي فلسطين يكون مسؤوؤم
لا اله موقع في الامم المتحده او موقع لا
قتله بفلسطين الوجود الفلسطيني عليه هجوم
فبالتالي موضوع حلت دولتين نعم يتم القضاء
عليه يوميا
الفلسطينيين
يستمر في النضال بالتاكيد من اجل تحقيق
دولتهم هذا مشروع الفلسطيني موجود لو تم
الاستسلام بانه دوله او دولتين لا يوجد لا
دوله ولا دولتين ولكن فلسطين سيستمرون في
ذلك في يوم من الايام سيخرج المستوطنين
يعني انا عندما اتفرج على المنطق اللي بين
رام الله ونابلس او المنطقه اللي وقعت
فيها عمليه عيله قبل يومين هذه المنطقه
اللي ربما 20 كم مربع سلسله من العمليات
النضاليه والفدائيه التي وقعت في هذه
المنطقه منذ 100 عام
ولكن يعني لما عندما تفكر فيها تجد انه
الشعب الفلسطيني في الفعل يجترح المعجزات
يعني في الزمن الانتداب البريطاني هناك
عمليه مشهوره في هذه المنطقه عندما اراد
الجنود البريطانيين ان ياخذوا باص فلسطيني
يسوق سائق فلسطيني لدخول لمنطقه فيها
مقاومين فالقى هذا السائق بنفسه وبالجنود
في الواد قتل نفسه وقتلهم بالواد ثائر
حماد الذي احضر بندقيه من الحرب العالميه
الثانيه في زمن الانتفاضه الثانيه وقنص
الجنود
ابو جمال ضراغم الذي لديه بيت يسمى خان
اللبن بين خمس مستوطنات ليله نهار يقاتل
هو وزوجته واولاده يعني هذا الصمود سيجعل
الدوله او الدولتين قائمه بالنهايه العوده
الفلسطيني لديهم يعني نقيض الصراع صفري
الان اصبح بين وجود فلسطيني ووجود اسرائيل
ولكن المشكله دكتور احمد
اذا اسقطنا حل الدولتين الكل يتحدث الان
اما عن دوله ابرتايد عمليا مثل ما اشار
الدكتور عزم وهناك باحثين اسرائيليين كثر
يقولون اذا استمرت الاوضاع بهذا الشكل ومع
تصاعد وتيره الاستيطان هذا ليس فقط ودا
لحل الدولتين وانما ايضا حتى
للحلم الصهيوني لانه اذا صارت الامور بهذا
الشكل لن تكون دوله اسرائيل كما ارادوها
نعم هذا صحيح هناك طيار
يكتب يطرح هذه الفكره هذه الحكومه على مدى
السنوات الماضيه
كبرت او وعدت حل الدولتين المجتمع الدولي
ما زال يؤمن بهذا الطرح بانه الحل الامثل
الحد الادنى الذي يمكن ان يتفق عليه
الاطراف ولكن عمليا على الواقع هذا الحل
اصبح بعيدا جدا
بسبب قرارات الحكومه الاسرائيليه واعتراف
نتنياهو او تفاخروا انه قضى عليه بالرغم
من انه استعمل تعبير دوله فلسطينيه عده
مرات في الماضي كضريبه كلاميه
نحن امام واقع ثنائي القوميه
من البحر للنهر
لا يوجد شيء اخر اما ان يكون النظام نظام
دوله ابارتايد من النهر للبحر او ان يكون
نظام ديمقراطي من البحر للنهر وفيه نظام
ديمقراطي الصوره تختلف ولذلك يقول بعض
الكتاب اليهود انه هذا نهايه حلم
الصهيونيه في هذه البلاد غالبا السيناريو
الاصح والاكثر قربا للواقع هو تعميق نظام
الابارتايد يوما بعد يوم في كل المجالات
لانه في هناك
حكومه تسيطر داخل
اسرائيل كدوله
على نظام قانوني معين بينما تسيطر على
ملايين الفلسطينيين تحت حكم عسك بلا حقوق
بلا حقوق مدنيه بلا حق التظاهر اصلا مش بس
حق التصويت لكي يؤثر على مستقبلهم في دوله
واحده بلا حق التظاهر ولذلك اعود واكرر ما
اقوله انه الفلسطيني لديه حق الدفاع عن
النفس هذا الحق المنزوع حتى طبقا للقانون
الدولي عنده حق حتى تبقى للكانون
الاسرائيلي في عنده
حق للدفاع عن نفسه لمن يحاول الاعتداء على
بيتك او احراكه اذا نحن امام سيناريو
مستقبلي اللي يبعدنا عن حل الدولتين طالما
بقي المجتمع الدولي بهذه الحاله الصامته
الركود يعطي اسرائيل ان تتصرف كما تشاء
ولكن هناك عامل اخر هو صمود هذا الشعب
الفلسطيني الذي يجترح
نضال كل العالم يشهد له وحيدا على الارض
نعم هو وحيدا كما تفضل الدكتور صبري وحيدا
على الارض في
غالبيه نواحي الحياه اذا كان في هناك
اسناد اسناد دولي اسناد غربي اسناد عربي
اسناد اسلامي ربما النفس يكون اقوى
والصمود يكون
اسهل والتحدي دائما امام هذا الشعب انه
يحب الحياه اذا ما استطاع اليها سبيلا
طفلا وامراه وشيخا مع انه في العقدين
الاخيرين اسرائيل قتلت اكثر من 1400 طفل
ما اقل من عمر 18 عاما ودائما تقول نحن لا
نقتل الاطفال وانما نخطئ وانا اقول يعني
الواحد بيخطئ مره واحده عشر مرات عشرين
مره ولكن لا يخطئ
من الف مره اكثر من الف طفل هذا هو
الاحتلال كل احتلال وهذا الاحتلال لا
يختلف عن الاحتلالات الاخرى في العالم هنا
دكتور الطيبي سرع باعطائنا سيناريوهات كما
يراها للفتره المقبله نرى مع الدكتور صيدم
ما الذي يراه من سيناريوهات في ضوء ما كنا
نقود فيه الى حد الان فيما يتعلق
بالاستيطان ومستقبل التسويه ثم ننهي مع
الدكتور اعزم هنا في الاستديو تفضل دكتور
صيدا
يعني اخي محمد اذا ما نظرت الى خارطه
الاستيطان نعم كما تفضلتم بالتقرير مئات
المستوطنات ولكن هناك ثلاث مستوطنات
اساسيه اريال في الشمال معالي ادومين في
الوسط وغش عطسيون في الجنوب تقريبا كلها
موضعه بطريقه تقتل الجغرافيا الفلسطيني
الان الحديث عن مستوطنه مثلا مستوطنه غوش
او جبعات مطوس وهي هضاب الطائره انصحه صحه
الترجمه بالعربي هذه ستقضي تماما على
تواصل الجغرافيا لذلك عندما ياتي سموتريتش
وتاخذ الحكومه قرارات مستعجله وتسهل وصول
المستوطنين وازدياد اعدائه اعدادهم
وتوسعهم هي تعني تماما قتل الجغرافيا
الفلسطينيه وبالتالي انا اتفق مع القول
بان النافذه اللي دائما زوار الاجانب
يحدثون عنها نافذه احتماليه ان تولد دوله
فلسطينيه الى جانب اسرائيل بالفعل اوشكت
على الاغلاق ان لم تكن قد اغلقت تماما
لذلك اسرائيل تتعامل معنا وكانه عصبه من
البشر نريد ان نذكرها بانه الحرب التي تشن
عليها لان اسرائيل اكتشفت فجاه بان عدد
السكان الفلسطينيين من البحر الى النهر هو
اكبر من عدد السكان الاسرائيليين وبالتالي
تخوض حرب اباده مستعجله وتدخل في ماراثون
عنصري غير مسبوق تريد من خلاله الاجهاز
على الفلسطينيين لذلك لم اجد حرجا بالامس
عندما نشرت مقال في لندن عنوانه لا دوله
لا دولتان دوله في المريخ هكذا ترى
اسرائيل بانه الشعب الفلسطيني لا يستحق
دولي لا يستحق حياه هو بالنسبه الها ازمه
يشكل ازمه وتريد ان تصدروا الى اي كوكب
اخر السيناريو الذي اراك فلسطيني وما
استشعره على الارض بانه بشويه دعم
انساني وجداني عربي على مستوى الشعوب
بشويه اراده وعزيمه وكثير من الاصرار
الفلسطيني الذي اراه في الشوارع السيناريو
الوحيد هو اقامه دوله فلسطينيه لانه اذا
اسرائيل ترى لا مجال لحل الدولتين وترفض
حل الدوله الواحده وتتعامل معنا بانه احنا
حفنا من البشر طب عندما تستفيق صباح اليوم
التالي كما يقال دائما في سنريوهات الحرب
والسلم عندما تستفيق في اليوم التالي
وتسال السؤال الاكبر طب لا دولتين ولا
دوله طب اي دوله تريد انت تعتقد انك ترحل
الفريق قدم كره قدم او عصبه من الناس او
حفنه من البشر وتلقي فيهم على الحدود او
تريد ان تستفيق ذات يوم وترى الفلسطيني قد
حزم حقائب وسافر هذا لن يكون اخي الحبيب
انت ترى اليوم البيوت تهدم في القدس وفي
كل مكان الناس تسكن على ركامها وانا ازور
العائلات واستشعر من خلال حديثهم حجم
الاراده والعزيمه والاصرار وما يريدونه هو
فقط الدعم المعنوي لذلك احنا امام حقيقه
ماثله بوجودنا جميعا كفلسطينيين مصرين على
مقارعه المحتل بانه السيناريو الوحيد هو
اقامه دوله فلسطينيه عاصمتها القدس ولن
يكون هناك اي حل اخر ولا يمكن لاسرائيل ان
تفوز في النهايه كلما زادت الضغط كلما
زادت الضغط المضاد
دكتور عزم خاصه مع ظهور نوعيه جديده من
المقاومه الفلسطينيه الان صحيح نحن نتحدث
عن مقاومه جديده ربما عن ثلاث انواع من
المقاومه الموجوده هناك مقاومه تقوم على
العسكره بالفعل كما نراها في جنين القريبه
من الجهاد الاسلامي هناك مقاومه النمط
ثاني ربما اسميه النمط الحركي الذي تقوم
عليه كتائب متر علينا الاسود ومن وحركه
فتح وهويه حركه فتح بما فيهم اعضاء
بالاجهزه الامنيه فلدينا هذا النمطين
مقاومه عسكره وحركي ولدينا التنظيم
المركزي الذي تمثله حماس وعملياتها
الاخيره وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن حركه
مقاومه من اشكال مختلفه ربما ثلاث اشكال
مختلفه متسعه موجوده في الضفه الغربيه
الان في الوقت الحالي وبالتالي هذه منتشره
يقابلها مشروع استيطاني فيه نظام عقوبات
جماعيه يصل الى درجه محاوله احراق قرى
باكملها عريف
حواره لدينا مشروع استيطاني يريد ان يشرعن
الاستيطان باسرع وقت ممكن ولدينا ايضا عدا
عن ذلك لدينا استيطان مستمر ومنتشر هذه
الوصفه تؤدي الى سيناريو واضح مع الفراغ
الدبلوماسي الدولي عدم اكتراث العالم
العالم الان ياتي للفلسطينيين بدل ان
يتحدث معهم عن الاستيطان يتحدث معهم عن
وانا هذا ربما شاهدته بنفسي في بعض
اللقاءات يتحدث عن قانون حمايه الاسره
يتحدث عن المناهج التعليم عن الاسرى
وبالتالي لدينا فراغ دولي حركه مقاومه
مستمره استيطار وحركه استيطانيه غير
مسبوقه من التطرف الايديولوجي هذه وصفه
الانفجار عندما يحدث الانفجار انذاك
سيتدخل مجتمع الدولي
سيكون هناك رده فعل على التطبيع العربي
سيكون هناك رده فعل على كل شيء عندما يحدث
هذه الوصفه الانفجار واراها قادمه انا اذا
استمرت الامور كما نراها الان اذا لم
يتدخل لانه كما راينا في شرم الشيخ
والعقبه فشلت في ان تبرم اي شيء جديد
عندما يحدث هذا الانفجار سيتدخل العالم
حتى يضع شروط جديده وربما انذاك يحدث
التغير داخل اسرائيل
ويحدث تراجع الى الخلف بفضل الصمود
الفلسطيني الذي سيجبر العالم على التدخل
شكرا جزيلا لك يا دكتور احمد جميل لازم
شكرا لك دكتور احمد الطيبي من القدس وشكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور صبري صيدم من رام الله
دمتم في رعايه الله موعدنا يتجدد الاسبوع
المقبل باذن الله مع سيناريوهات جديد في
امان الله
[موسيقى]